I want to do a story about this idea that
an ounce of prevention is really worth a pound
of cure.
There are some states that did not take coronavirus
seriously early on.
And those states are the ones that now are
having some of the largest outbreaks in the
world.
On a case growth rate basis and some of them
are being forced to now go in the complete
opposite direction and adopt some of the even
more authoritarian techniques or rules than
we saw in some of the early hotspots.
And we talked earlier about California, Florida,
Arizona, Carolinas, Tennessee, Louisiana,
Mississippi, you know, red states, plus California,
basically.
But I want to talk about Texas briefly right
now.
Texas hesitated to do much early on in the
pandemic.
Texas then after sort of closing some stuff,
they started reopening very quickly.
Mask use was not high in Texas for a livery
longtime there.
Republican Lieutenant Governor Dan Patrick.
You might remember, went on TV and said, I
would sacrifice myself.
And I know many other grandparents would as
well to corona virus to save the economy.
But things have gotten so ugly so quickly
in Texas.
I see use very full hospitals, very full approaching
what I'm calling virus escape velocity in
Texas, that Hidalgo County, Texas, issued
a threat that a notice, I guess I would call
it that if you test positive for the virus
and you break the mandatory 14 day quarantine,
you will be prosecuted criminally.
The Hidalgo County Twitter account tweeted
this out, making it clear, do not leave your
house.
Do not have any visitors.
Make a list of people that you have been in
contact with and you are subject to criminal
prosecution if you don't comply with this.
Now, there's a few things here, of course,
to think about.
One is, are they really going to prosecute?
I don't know.
They're certainly threatening to.
Now, of course, a lot of Texas right wingers
are saying things like this is the Gestapo.
These are jackbooted government thugs.
The truth is actually the opposite.
If a place needs to do something like this,
it's because people are not doing it already
in any common, sensible world.
You would never need such a notice because
obviously anybody who test positive would
not be leaving their house.
They would be home for 14 days because they
understand the risk of continuing to spread
the disease.
The fact that this was published is a signal
about how bad the situation is.
And meanwhile, if we zoom out from Hidalgo
County to Texas more broadly, the death curve
is looking very, very ugly.
A very steep spike in the seven day moving
average of death numbers in Texas.
No sign that things are turning around.
Remember, we have a progression, which is
cases spike, hospitalizations, spike, and
then deaths spike early in the case, spike
in sort of like mid to late June.
There were a lot of deniers, I would call
them, who were just repeating cases aren't
going to lead to deaths.
It's younger people getting it.
We are better at treating it.
It's less serious now.
We know all these different Compaq pick your
poison, so to speak.
And I was interested in that.
And I came to you and I said, this may be
true or it may just be the 20 day lag time.
Then we started to see hospitalizations increase
in Texas.
We heard in Houston that a bunch of icey used
were getting full.
We heard in Austin, the mayor of Austin was
concerned about how full they were getting.
That was the sign that this may just be a
lag time.
It may be, as we've seen, cases followed by
hospitalizations, followed by deaths and case
in point.
That is what we are seeing right now.
Now, the big hot spots in the U.S., again,
reminder, it's basically California and a
bunch of red states.
Dr. Foushee a couple of weeks ago said we
could be heading towards 100000 cases per
day.
We've been sort of steadying on weekdays between
60 and 75000 cases per day.
I wouldn't be shocked if we do an eighty thousand
new case day this week if things do not turn
around again.
I know I'm doing this twice today, but it's
so important.
I know we have a lot of viewers in these in
these areas.
We are going to reach virus escape velocity.
And by August 15th, it could make today look,
not that bad.
And that's very, very scary.
So we haven't won.
This is not what winning looks like.
Do not be confused.
Not that many of you are, but most of you
understand that we are not winning.
And forget about August 15th.
What's the fall going to look like if we never
flatten the curve?
Remember, we were expecting a total dip to
almost no new cases, almost no new deaths
by June 1st or June 15th.
It never happened.
We had a slight decline, down to 20000 cases
a day and then back up like a rocket.
What will the fall look like
if
this doesn't turn around?